[Music]
he imagined just a week ago tomorrow on
the right this was what's happening in
Windsor on the right you see royal
wedding photographer that's Alexi Weber
mouse key and his wife heading into
Windsors st. George's Chapel for last
Saturday's royal wedding his images of
Prince Harry and Meghan Markel captured
the couple's joy on that day and they
gained worldwide attention Loomer
mirskiy was invited to the wedding after
taking their engagement photos last year
and those were already iconic and just
over a month before the big day
Kensington Palace called him again he
took those official wedding portraits of
the Duke and Duchess of Sussex on
Saturday the acclaimed fashion
photographer look at this guy's work
he's got cred he's worked his work as
grace of covers of numerous magazines
including Bogue Ellen Harper's Bazaar
Alexei [ __ ] mirskiy is here at the
table for an interview you'll see only
on CBS this morning because when we saw
you in Windsor you said this will be the
biggest job of your career so far and
the pictures are gorgeous Alaska thank
you for giuse so when did you know you
had the shot because you had 25 minutes
to shoot six photos yeah I think it was
one of those rare occasions when I had
no time to look at the screen when I was
taking pictures and usually you take a
couple of frames you look at you take
everything in position and so it really
had a hundred percent of faith in my
assistants who are watching the screen I
said you just tell me if anything needs
fixing because I'm just gonna be
concentrating on the family and getting
the kids are looking and so it wasn't
until way after in the afternoon when
all the I got the files on a hard drive
and I was in the car on the way back to
my mother's and I was so nervous yeah
and then I was going through the
pictures and kind of like flicking
flicking thinking and all of a sudden
you see the one relief and it's very
emotional tell us about this picture
where they're sitting down and you
really captured I thought Harry's just
beautiful smile and kind of a joy of the
most did you tell him to do that pose
did you say that we were like I said we
had three minutes on that on that
position on that on that set up and so I
said let's walk out to the Rose Garden
and as we walk down they were sort of
hugging and it was this relief and
happiness and then on the way back I
said listen just sit down here and she
just found her into that position and
they were laughing and they were
this constant smiling you know fix her
hair to be perfect like that I just felt
like that naturally just flex yeah how
do you in a moment like that do you just
hope that it happens or do you how do
you set people at ease when you've got
such a short period of time a good
question I have no idea I think it's
just something I I know I just tried to
be the sort of relaxed as possible I've
always said that I'm not one of these
artists who sort of wants to force my
vision on people I want to document
people I want to I want them to be seen
which is probably why but the Queen
appears to be smiling though Alexi
that's one of the things you were
concerned about how do you get the Queen
to smile do you say okay mom let's try
that again
he's smiling how did you do that I think
she was probably smelling at my efforts
to make the kids or look at the screen
what did you do to do that I'd overheard
some the chaos of the kids before and I
overheard somebody offering them a
smartie and Smarties their English M&M
okay okay and so as I got them all onto
internet places I screamed out who likes
Smarties and everybody went me and I
think all the ad even some of the adults
went me and everybody else smile perhaps
the Queen like Smarties - yeah Kevin
Eric do you go into a massive picture
like that with a game plan or do you
just hope I mean obviously you know
where they've kind of the bodies are
gonna go but how much of it is planned
beforehand and how much of is just
improvisation in the moment I I like to
plan as much as possible so that if
everything goes wrong at least I can
fall back onto that base plan but it
pretty much went according to plan the
only thing that wasn't sort of the
unknown was the children and they
behaved magnificently say what was what
was the mood like where that was there a
lot of conversation with Harry and Megan
to each other was a royal family talking
amongst themselves what was it like we
had 25 minutes to shoot these six setups
yeah so it was pretty people were
getting sort of moved around quite
quickly uh-huh but in between shots I
glanced over my shoulder and it was like
a it was like a family room at any
family occasion you know the brothers
are talking the children are being
wrangled by parents grandparents talking
to their children it was just a normal
it was very beautiful sight you know
lots of happy family moment how many
people now want you to take their
wedding picture
how many calls are you eating yeah are
you getting people calling you I'm
getting lots of emails of people who are
getting married soon and also people who
have gotten married already and didn't
like the pictures and want to reshoot it
I loved reading that you are a stamp
collector as a kid yes now seeing that
this photo is on stamps yeah that was so
cool
be part of a historical record like this
yeah it's amazing I think that's the
thing is that the pressure going into
this I kept saying to myself it's just
another picture he's gonna make it look
good just like every other job and
everybody kept whispering in my ear
saying but this is gonna go down in
history but now it is a stamp though
Alexi that's very oh it's amazing
very very cool all right Alexei
Ratmansky you've had your historical
moment thank you so much congratulations
rats